[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you know when I was young we used to
play this game called Gay Chicken they
called it
uh I didn't name the game but I was you
know I I the game existed and then I I
then I existed
um was it your uncle was a neighbor well
the game was you you and a buddy you'd
grab each other's wiener right penis
they called it in those days some of you
guys call it penis but uh yeah you grab
it and the first person to get an
erection lost the game right
so it's like arm wrestling first it's
the stupidest [ __ ] game no it's not
no symbol I mean it is did you win did
you ever win or did you lose did you
lose a lot or did you win a lot oh I did
real well one season uh what is the gay
chicken season what does that go from
it's more of a win I would say it's an
Autumn game yeah I would say it's kind
of well that's what I think I can see it
now all the leaves changing colors and
just the two of you what do you play
with neighbors or their teams no you
just got them we only had about seven
guys that played in our little bracket
or whatever but they had you know what's
weird you know what's interesting you
have seven guys in your bracket yet it's
uh two-man game yeah and so there's an
odd number oh yeah does it have to be
two-man can't you like do it in a circle
oh come on lady no
come on man that's y'all are messed up
y'all are first dude I'll tell you what
we did one time so we had a dent in a
car a vehicle or whatever you guys call
them and um yeah and do we caught a
couple of pigeons and got them to [ __ ]
over the dent oh you just held the
pigeon over there kept feeding it
squeezed it we didn't beat him oh [ __ ]
pretty soon after you hold them
and we turned it in and when it had this
kind of you know uh
kind of a just a [ __ ] finish I guess on
it and they didn't see the dead they
didn't see the damage you know smart so
that's kind of an old school thing I
guess or new school
but hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Francis Foster I'm Constance and
kissing and this is a show for you if
you want honest conversations with
Fascinating People a brilliant guest
today is already taking the piss out of
us it's the amazing American comedian
Theo Vaughn welcome to trigonometry you
guys have we call it autism
I don't know what you guys call it bro
but we got it over here everybody's got
it they had a comedy room near me this
gentleman had half a limb
and he was uh he was missing part of his
leg I think or he said he was
so he could have been faking it CGI or
something I don't know what his name was
I mean it was a
CJ no it's a white dude perfect yeah so
are you gonna go to space do you think
Logan because I was I was thinking about
that they're doing that now they're
doing that no I I am gonna go yeah I'd
like to go it's on my bucket list I
don't want to die in this planet dude
really I don't wanna like for real for
real I don't want to die on this planet
that is a very rich thing to say
it really is I don't want to die with
these poor peasants the rest of us are
trying to find quarters in our car to
get that air machine to [ __ ] fill up
our tire at the gas station in this
guy's like I'm not done I will just
flaunt it
a video though dude we'll be well we'll
be down here dying there he is you know
Austin Hooper Jersey
that's so funny you have other people I
don't want to die in this neighborhood
it's like the projects I gotta get out
of here he's trying to leave to go to
Mars for a [ __ ] funeral that no one
could go to who's gonna attend that Jeff
Bezos somebody out there dude there'll
be somebody out there a couple of perms
yeah to be out there
who would be at that dinner dude at that
Saturn supper huh who would be happy on
that thing Bezos mosque
yeah dude he didn't [ __ ] Moon Meats
what's it called the ephraimactic yeah
oh he cured him that guy that was a wild
one thank God for him man got to protect
him yeah yeah but just thank God for you
know thank God for freaking podcasting
yeah for real yeah could you imagine oh
my God having to go on the news and talk
about something
oh my God bro I would pay somebody to
look at my [ __ ] if I had to do that
man how much children that too
but only in my family
and only in my neighborhood dude only to
give back to the community you need like
a Venn diagram to me man you've got to
keep going man you got to get back to
your roots man Theo you're from
Louisiana what do you think about this
guy yeah
um when you said Landry I knew he was
from there that's the only place I've
ever heard that name what part are you
from I'm from Houma oh yeah
dude home is a good place really
it's a good place to have a friend it's
real soft down there the land is real
soft like you could be talking to
somebody and then they just [ __ ]
I'm not even joking bro and people are
so nice they'll listen as they just
[ __ ] go straight
they just sink into the ground I'd love
to stay but
oh and his family partially owned the
place it was a business next door they
sold wine
like garyvee or whatever a guy's name is
Jerry V telling people to [ __ ] sell
their home and sleep in their yard you
know what I'm saying and that dude was
raised on a damn wine wine farm or
something dude he's into that [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying dude hiding
grapes in his ass at night freezing
grapes and [ __ ] hiding him in his ass
and he's telling people how to struggle
dude that guy out of his mind he's like
oh damn dude oh you still have
silverware in your house [ __ ] sell it
and then he shows up and he'll like hug
the dude the guy can't even he has no
way to get food in his mouth you know
the guy's [ __ ] just knuckling through
some chowder knuckling through some
Booyah base and he's like no worries man
you mean 76 last night and he hugs him
you know what I'm saying it's like what
the [ __ ]
and then he drives off and the family's
just standing there and apart
another winner out of his [ __ ]
mine dude
and he hugs oh he sold two extra
Christmas sweaters you didn't need from
last year and they're playing together
like what is going on dude
um but anyway I don't and look man I
gotta give some love to my boy I'm sorry
the videos I'm not saying the guy's not
a smart guy the videos though and the
guy it grew up well off well no I think
he actually didn't grow up well off
that's part of his that's gonna be lying
no you partially lined but it's not
really lying if you don't know but he
was he grew up you know his dad owned
like a corner liquor store or something
and he did you know he got after it
created the uh but in my neighborhood a
corner liquor store is she was a winery
so if you're looking at it from baby
from theobon's perspective hell yeah he
grew up like big time oh yeah look at
these dudes over here huh
slang in that Reese laying there he's
vaping this is a crazy question is you
can Vape inside most people looking at
me like let me hit it all right yeah
mostly I think most people just don't
care but like imagine light up a
cigarette inside of a Cheesecake Factory
they've been probably tough I mean look
on the FBI for sure yeah yeah I don't
think yeah because vaping people usually
blow it down their pant leg or blow it
like yeah the turtleneck out somewhere
yeah yeah and there's even shirts I saw
where it's made for Vaping secretly
vaping
suit it's like a a vaping shirt
they have pocket tees that hold your
Vape in the corner
no I'm talking about hold the [ __ ]
smoke oh damn that ghillie suit there
was a dude next time who didn't give a
[ __ ] on the flight people would be
sleeping on flight full smoke that's a
black dude bro
just say what you want to say Mr Joe
video taping this hey hey Theo Theo okay
look can you we gonna role play all
right all right you my girl and you just
gonna break up with me oh [ __ ] break up
with me all right just break up with you
yeah can I
I'm just asking can I use the n-word or
not
ah
i a
[ __ ]
hey
Theo I don't care but when we step out
of here I can't help
but you using at your discretion okay
[Music]
do whatever you want
hey Alice hey hey
what's up baby what's going on you know
what the [ __ ] up boo
my little
[Laughter]
baby why do you censoring the word [ __ ]
you know you're saying
that was A call came in I ain't
censoring [ __ ]
I know you've been out there with Mr Joe
petting them [ __ ] white animals what
what baby what
what I know you've been out there with
Papa Joe
petting them little [ __ ] honking
Muppets
LaShonda you crazy baby look
um not as crazy as your homeless asses
I'm out this relationship my
[Applause]
son
has currently been disconnected
we had a dude
um
when I was growing up this dude we
stayed at his house one time this guy
Curtis and he knows it he has a big dick
I could tell by his name he actually bro
he has a big dick and a gay brother dude
damn if you got a game brother you have
a big dick first thousand percent you
know guys or if you're a cop cops got
back the cops are packing dick really
usually I mean the highway patrol
generally has a bigger opinion I gotta
look that up all right
um
so Curtis yeah he had a bunch of animals
at his house like he probably had 20
animal cages in his room and I was so
scared I couldn't go to sleep he had
snakes ferrets were you sleeping at his
house yeah we was having a sleepover
right and uh and that night his dad
actually jerked off into the fire I
remember the story yeah well also though
in the middle of the night his dog was
barking a lot the dad went out there
shot it what
that's the middle of the night that's
Louisiana and no one did [ __ ] dude I
wouldn't [ __ ] going to defend that
dog yet it just lost you know and I
barely knew the father you know what
kind of gun was it I mean it sounded
like a gun yeah pistol yeah I don't
think he'd go out there with something
bigger than that yeah you gotta yeah
that's if you're gonna shoot a pit bull
it's Gotta Be You I don't think you do a
shotgun but also the dog you got to
recognize you're outside of the city
limits this dog has to know where he's
at like oh he knew you know there's kids
there's five kids sleeping over you're
gonna be up all night [ __ ] barking
like unless it's a murderer out in the
yard or something you gotta tighten it
up for the night I'll tell you this much
those other animals probably right after
church everybody was quiet that's it the
ferrets shut the [ __ ] up everybody was
chill the spider you know quiet as [ __ ]
quiet as a mouse oh had put on eight
slippers and [ __ ] went to bed bro
everybody chilled out so Patrick let's
talk about it what do you do for a
living opiates
thank you
[Applause]
I'm just joking dude that's when I
really started to like being a part of
recovery
and there's all types of it you know I
mean this stuff for everything there's
recovery for people that wear shirts
that don't fit or that fit too tightly
yeah
sorry it's really it drags me down
hanging around with Echo because
of each other and it just turns into a
bad thing I gotta say I see who your
dealer is obviously okay you guys
meeting up behind the freaking AutoZone
just [ __ ] pick up a couple extra
Smalls dude the sad part is there is a
small boy out there somewhere right now
maybe you don't have a [ __ ] I don't have
a shirt on here you should see the last
question we ask and this is going to
sound funny given what you've just said
is what's the one thing
bad not bad
it's been a long day dude you ask him
the question yeah okay so Theo the last
question we always ask is what's the
thing
[Music]
is this mere this is a good mirror yeah
it is a good mirror did this chain be
out the whole time oh no it's good
all right what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
um
[Music]
I think they
oh dude I remember one time I saw these
massive Birds right they call them in
Europe yeah it's beautiful strong
ah
I swear bro I went to this I went to
this place called Newcastle have you
heard of this yes yeah Newcastle and
this taxi drops me off and there was
these it was like a part like a
I don't know if it was look like a
bachelorette party or something and and
this foyer of like a big there was a big
room like a big window and they were in
there naked you know what do you call it
tits yes yes tits and they were beating
each other with pillows in there bro and
I sat out there and watched smoke the
cigarette out there
right out there and that's the one thing
no one's talking about huh
there was seven of these women in there
I can see why you brought it up yeah
it was serious man oh
that was fantastic well
it was serious bro see I can't even do
it justice because you can't even
believe that it could happen could you
[Music]
how who would get seven women naked and
have them pillow fight in front of a big
huge pitcher window so almost thought
they wanted to be seen for you I don't
know man that's [ __ ] that's beautiful
bro
[Music]